since debuting in 2017 Riverdale has
pushed the boundaries of network
television by placing the familiar and
formerly innocuous characters of Archie
comics into increasingly outlandish
plots season 4 is set to premiere in the
fall of 2019 and we've got everything
you need to know the first season of
Riverdale hit the CW as a midseason
addition in January 2017 that first
short set of 13 episodes proved so
popular that the CW brought the show
back as quickly as possible
promoting it to a fall debut for season
number two with a full order of 22
episodes beginning with season 2 and
into season 3 Riverdale led off the CW's
Wednesday night programming airing at
8:00 p.m. that's not broken so the
network isn't going to fix it Riverdale
will continue on its fourth season with
that same Wednesdays at 8:00 o'clock
timeslot on June 17th 2019 the official
Riverdale Instagram page gave fans the
exact date when the show would return
October 9th
it will serve as the lead-in to a
similar old concept new approach mystery
show Nancy Drew on March 4th 2019
Riverdale cast member Luke Perry died
suddenly at the age of 52
shortly after suffering a stroke the
first episode to air after the passing
of the actor who played Archie's sweet
father Fred Andrews came with a title
card reading in memoriam Luke Perry 1966
2019 the final installment to feature
Perry as Andrews debuted in late April
with the actor's final scene being a one
on one with Archie offering his boy
words of guidance and encouragement
Riverdale writers didn't explicitly deal
with the fate of Fred in season 3 but
will in season 4 I'm June 19th 2019
showrunner Roberto aguirre-sacasa
tweeted out the title page of the script
for the first episode of season four and
it's titled chapter 58 in memoriam
probably the most important episode of
Riverdale will do this year if not ever
a tribute to our fallen friend thankful
for this opportunity to honor Luke and
Fred this heavily implies that the Fred
Andrews character will be laid to rest
at San Diego comic-con 2019
aguirre-sacasa announced that the
episode would feature a special guest
star shannen doherty perry psychotics
Green partner from there Dylan and
Brenda days on Beverly Hills 90210 apart
from the tragic loss of Luke Perry as
Fred Andrews the main cast of Riverdale
will all be back for season four the
series will also welcome some
high-profile guest stars both familiar
in brand-new Archie's parents are
divorced and his mother lived far away
so Molly Ringwald only appeared
occasionally as Mary Andrews but the
loss of Perry Ringwald will likely up
her involvement aguirre-sacasa told TV
Line in May of 2019 we've talked about
Molly having a bigger presence next year
to help her son Chad Michael Murray will
also return as Edgar ever never the
creepy yet charming leader of the farm
the bizarre organ harvesting cult that
tore Betty's family apart and on that
subject
Wyatt Nash is set for recurring arc as
Charles Smith an FBI agent who also
happens to be Betty's long-lost brother
at Riverdale high teen TV veteran Kerr
Smith will play tough new school
principal mr. honey Sam Witwer best
known for his roles as mr. Hyde on once
upon a time an agent Liberty on
Supergirl will join the show as a
troubled writing teacher who becomes a
mentor figure for Jughead when the
crown-wearing kid ships off to a fancy
prep school the fourth season of
Riverdale will also mark its character's
fourth year at Riverdale High senior
year is an important time for so many
teenagers and it will be for Archie in
the game too it figures so large in
their lives that regular normal high
school stuff will take prominence in the
action of Riverdale's upcoming episodes
Camila Mendez who plays Veronica told
Entertainment Weekly at Comic Con season
4 is definitely senior year high school
focused more about relationships and
those dynamics meanwhile jugheads time
away from Riverdale could prove
problematic for his relationship with
Betty according to actor Cole Sprouse we
told Entertainment Tonight jugheads only
back in Riverdale on the weekends I
think that is going to inevitably put
stress on the relationship between Betty
and Jughead I think it might be a little
bit tense they might fall turn away from
each other only to come back together
way stronger but we'll team drama
supplant pitch-black plots like the
black hoods killing spree for Archie's
involvement in a deadly underground
boxing ring
you're doing great all right how many of
these guys my fighting not quite Mendez
added that Riverdale will certainly
explore the mystery of what we saw at
the end of season 3 a bleak
flash-forward depicting a blood-soaked
Archie Betty and Veronica Lily Reinhardt
who plays Betty also promises that early
in season four the show will introduce
another major mystery Riverdale can't
always be about mystery solving teens in
grave danger every so often the series
breaks the tension with a fun high
concept episode a 2018 installment
flashed back to Riverdale high
20-something years ago centering on the
antics of the present-day adults of
Riverdale when they were teens and
portrayed by the show's young cast
members a few months later a meta
self-referential episode found Riverdale
High's drama club staging a musical
production of the high school cult
classic Heather's now how in God's name
is a play about teen violence and
suicide a good idea in Riverdale
Riverdale season 4 will offer at least
one such novelty installment the fourth
episode of the season airing on October
30th marks the show's first ever
Halloween themed chapter aguirre-sacasa
mentioned it during the show's comic-con
panel saying we've got a really fun
spooky episode for everyone I know what
Archie's gonna be dressed as and we're
trying to get clearance on some DC comic
book characters considering that
Riverdale shares a network with DC's
arrowverse shows we may be in for some
tongue-in-cheek superhero related
Halloween fun check out one of our
newest videos right here plus the even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]